¡Estonia es un país! (SILENCIO INCÓMODO
DE UNOS SEGUNDOS) Vale, lo sé, puede que
parezca una obviedad… pero seguro que muchos
de los que estáis viendo este vídeo no sabíais
que existe un país que se llama Estonia.
Y es una pena porque, si hay un país que
debería ser un modelo a seguir… ese es
Estonia. De entrada, es el primer estado en
reconocer Internet como un derecho básico
para todos sus ciudadanos. Pero hoy vamos
a centrarnos en otro aspecto muy destacable
de este país. Atentos.
Estonia tiene el sistema de impuestos más
competitivo de toda la OECD
¡Ya sé lo que estáis pensando! ¿Impuestos?
¿Competitivo? ¡Estonia debe ser un paraíso
fiscal! ¡Mejor aún! Debe ser el Hollywood
de los paraísos fiscales. A su lado, Islas
Caimán parecería Suecia. Pues no, tranquilos.
Por ejemplo, el impuesto de sociedades en
Estonia está en el 20%. El IRFP está también
en un 20%. Está claro que no son impuestos
tremendamente altos. Pero tampoco es un Islas
Mauricio, ni un Liechtenstein… ¡Ni siquiera
una Suiza! Sin embargo, pese a no tener impuestos
especialmente bajos, Estonia ha atraído a
un montón de empresas y es la cuna de startups
como Skype, TransferWise o Bolt. De hecho,
tienen una política muy original para atraer
empresas y talento: la residencia electrónica.
Lo contamos con más detalle en un vídeo
que os dejo en la descripción. Para que os
hagáis una idea, ese vídeo es de los primeros
que hicimos en VisualPolitik. Por aquel entonces,
sólo unos pocos habían solicitado esta residencia
electrónica. Ahora hay más de 70.000 ciber
ciudadanos. Tal vez no os parezca un número
muy grande… Pero recordad que la población
de Estonia son sólo un millón de habitantes.
Y diréis: vale, fenomenal, Estonia puede
ser un pequeño Silicon Valley. Pero ¿Y qué
tal se vive por ahí? ¿Hasta qué punto no
están sacrificando los servicios públicos
a favor de la economía? ¿Tienen estado del
bienestar? Y la respuesta es que sí. Al igual
que casi todos los países Europeos, Estonia
tiene un estado del bienestar: sanidad pública,
educación pública ¡Y carreteras! ¡No sólo
eso! Su sistema educativo es uno de los mejores
del mundo. Según el informe PISA, Estonia
es el quinto país con la mejor educación,
superando incluso a Finlandia. Además, servicios
como el transporte público salen a coste
0 para el ciudadano. Es decir, que si estáis
paseando por las calles de Tallin o Tartu,
podéis subiros al tranvía sin tener que
comprar un billete. Tal cual como lo oís.
Y ya sé lo que pensaréis muchos ¡Seguro
que Estonia se puede permitir todo eso porque
son super ricos! ¿De verdad pueden seguir
su modelo los países más pobres? Pues lo
cierto es que Estonia está lejos de ser un
país de millonarios. Al contrario: hasta
los años 90 formaban parte de la Unión Soviética.
Hace sólo 30 años, este país no sólo estaba
atrasado sino que, además, vivía bajo la
continua amenaza de una invasión rusa. Vamos,
que tenían todas las papeletas para terminar
como una Ucrania en miniatura. Sin embargo,
hoy en día generan noticias como esta.
Estonia se convierte en el único país del
mundo con presidenta y primera ministra mujeres
Así que ahora la pregunta es ¿Por qué decimos
que Estonia tiene el sistema fiscal más eficiente
del mundo… aunque no tenga impuestos especialmente
bajos? ¿Cómo funciona un país así? ¿Qué
lecciones puede dar Estonia a otros países?
Hoy vamos a responder a esta pregunta pero
antes, vamos a ver un poco de historia.
EL SALTO DEL TIGRE
Nuestra historia comienza en el año 1996.
Muchos de vosotros ya habíais nacido. Alguno
incluso estaba bailando el Wannabe de las
Spice Girls, que por aquel entonces arrasaba
en el mundo desarrollado. En ese momento,
pocos habrían dado un céntimo por Estonia.
En lo que a economía respecta, estaba a un
nivel parecido al de Argelia o Colombia (al
menos, en términos de PIB per cápita en
paridad con el poder adquisitivo). A todo
esto hay que sumarle el desempleo, que no
dejaba de crecer, y la fuga de cerebros. Pensadlo
bien: Estonia se independizó de la Unión
Soviética en 1991. En pocos años, privatizaron
casi todas las empresas públicas y liberalizaron
los precios. Esto significa montones de personas
en el paro y una subida de precios importante.
Y, por supuesto, por aquel entonces, hablar
de Internet o de Nuevas Tecnologías era como
hablar de papel higiénico en una pandemia.
Y entonces, es cuando llegó este señor con
pajarita que veis en pantalla: THOMAS HENDRIK
ILVES. En aquella época era el embajador
de Estonia en Estados Unidos. Y dijo lo siguiente.
“Something that shaped my thinking regarding
Estonia: the idea that we should be getting
our young people to work with computers”
–Thomas Hendrik Ilves
Así es como nació la estrategia del SALTO
DEL TIGRE. Básicamente, Internet era una
revolución en ciernes. Aún era un territorio
nuevo: todos los países empezaban a explorar
sus posibilidades. En otras palabras, que
un país joven como Estonia tenía una ventana
de oportunidad para liderar esta revolución
¡Y vaya si lo hicieron! Desde que el señor
Ilves llegó de Estados Unidos con su idea
revolucionaria, el Gobierno priorizó los
ordenadores y Internet por encima de todas
las cosas. En pocos años, todos los colegios
Estonios tenían ordenadores. Desde el gobierno
se organizaron toda clase de campañas para
educar a los ciudadanos en el uso de nuevas
tecnologías. En el año 2005, Estonia fue
el primer país del mundo en organizar elecciones
con voto electrónico. Y en el año 2000,
el parlamento estonio reconoció el acceso
a Internet como derecho humano. Y todas estas
políticas dieron resultados inmediatos. De
la primera generación de estudiantes que
habían estudiado con ordenadores surgió
una primera ola de startups Made in Estonia
¿Recordáis el KAZAA? Por si no os acordáis,
se trata de uno de los primeros programas
para compartir archivos P2P ¿Os suena un
programa llamado SKYPE? Pues nació en estos
años.
¡Pero esperad un momento! Porque esta fue
la primera época dorada de Estonia. Pero
si pensáis que la historia de este país
ha sido siempre un campo de rosas… os equivocáis.
Rusia es acusada de lanzar una ciberguerra
para desestabilizar Estonia
Habéis oído bien: Estonia ha sido pionera
en muchas cosas, entre otras, en ser víctima
de ciberguerra. El primer ataque cibernético
hacia un estado de la historia se produjo
aquí, en el año 2007. Pensad que, por aquel
entonces, prácticamente toda la administración
de Estonia ya estaba digitalizada. Así que,
durante varios días, el país entero se colapsó.
Podríamos hablar largo y tendido sobre por
qué se produjo este ataque, pero lo vamos
a dejar para otro vídeo. Porque el mayor
problema de Estonia llegó un par de años
antes. Más concretamente con la gran crisis
financiera de 2009. Si hay un país golpeado
por esta crisis fue Estonia. Para que os hagáis
una idea, ese año, el PIB de Estados Unidos
cayó un 2,5%. El de España un 3,8%. Y acordaos
de el impacto que tuvo esa caída: lo llamamos
la gran crisis financiera por algo. Pues bien,
en Estonia, la caída del PIB fue de un 14,4%.
Es decir, que el país entero se fue a freir
churros. Y en ese momento de crisis existencial,
el gobierno se vio en un dilema: ¿Subimos
los impuestos? ¿Dejamos que nos rescaten?
¿O aplicamos políticas de austeridad extremas?
Es decir: austeridad con mayúsculas. Pues
eso es exactamente lo que ocurrió. De un
año para otro, el Gobierno de Estonia hizo
una pequeña bajada de impuestos y una bajada
salvaje de gasto público. Para que os hagáis
una idea, despidieron al 40% de los funcionarios.
Y diréis ¿Funcionó esta política? Pues…
podéis juzgar por vosotros mismos.
Aquí podéis ver el PIB per capita, en paridad
con el poder adquisitivo de Estonia. Si os
dais cuenta, en sólo 30 años, Estonia ha
superado a Grecia y Portugal y está acercando
posiciones con España. Todo esto es un auténtico
milagro si veis donde estaba cada uno en los
años 90. A día de hoy, el paro en Estonia
no llega ni al 6%. Y eso sumando los efectos
de la pandemia. Y la pregunta es ¿Cómo lo
han hecho? ¿Cuál es la fórmula mágica?
¿De verdad basta con tecnología y mucho
Internet para tener un país así? Ahora mismo
lo vamos a ver.
EL SISTEMA FISCAL MÁS COMPETITIVO DEL MUNDO
Ya sé lo que os estaréis preguntando todos
a estas alturas ¿Qué queremos decir cuando
hablamos de un sistema fiscal eficiente? De
entrada, hablamos de un ranking elaborado
por la TAX FOUNDATION. Como todos los rankings,
es muy discutible y no hay que tomarlo como
las sagradas escrituras. Pero es importante
que entendamos que competitivo no significa
necesariamente bajo. En muchos casos, no se
trata de cuantos impuestos pagamos sino de
cómo los pagamos.
Así que ¿Qué hace que Estonia sea tan competitiva?
Lo primero es lo simple que es su sistema
fiscal. Podemos resumir casi todos los impuestos
de Estonia con un número: el 20. 20% de impuesto
de la renta, 20% de IVA y 20% de impuesto
de sociedades. Simple y sencillo. En el caso
del impuesto de la renta, existen varias excepciones
para las rentas más bajas. Por ejemplo, si
tu sueldo es inferior a 6000 euros al año,
no pagas ningún impuesto. La franje que va
de los 6.000 a los 25.200 euros tiene tipos
reducidos. Pero a partir de 25.200 euros todo
el mundo paga exactamente lo mismo. No existe
ningún tipo de beneficio fiscal. En otras
palabras: no sólo es un impuesto simple sino
que también es neutral ¿Y qué significa
neutral? Pues que es un impuesto pensado únicamente
para recaudar. Y diréis ¡Pero un momento!
¿Es que los impuestos sirven para otra cosa
que no sea recaudar dinero para las arcas
del estado? ¡Por supuesto que sí! En muchos
otros países, como España, los impuestos
premian o castigan distintas decisiones. Por
ejemplo, para los que veáis este vídeo desde
Cataluña. Si invertís en empresas en expansión
que cotizan en el Mercado Alternativo Bursátil
podéis deduciros hasta 10.000 euros en vuestra
declaración de la renta. Pensadlo bien: esta
medida está incentivando un tipo de inversión
sobre otra. Es decir, que podría darse el
caso de que una persona invirtiera en la empresa
A antes que en la empresa B sólo por cuestiones
fiscales. En este caso hablamos de unos impuestos
muy poco neutrales. En Estonia sin embargo,
Hacienda no intenta promocionar ninguna inversión
en concreto. Esto tiene una doble ventaja:
no sólo es un sistema más justo sino que
también es mucho más sencillo: tan sencillo
que hacer una declaración de la renta en
este país lleva sólo 5 minutos. Y esto no
es una exageración.
Las imágenes que estáis viendo son de un
tutorial del Gobierno de Estonia sobre cómo
hacer la declaración de la renta. Tenéis
el enlace del vídeo completo en la descripción.
Literalmente hablamos de un proceso que se
puede hacer en 5 minutos y 13 segundos.
Pero, sin duda, la superventaja Estonia está
en su impuesto de sociedades: un tipo del
20%. Y diréis ¿Es un impuesto bajo? No exactamente.
En España está entre un 20 y un 25% dependiendo
del tamaño de la empresa. La superventaja
Estonia está en el cómo se paga ese impuesto.
De entrada, sólo tributamos cuando sacamos
el dinero de la empresa. Es decir, que si
reinvertimos los beneficios no pagamos ni
un duro. Además, no hay impuesto por dividendos,
con los que se evita la doble tributación.
Y, por encima de todo, las empresas estonias
pueden compensar las pérdidas de años anteriores
con las ganancias de otros años. Y, de nuevo,
tanto pagar impuestos como crear una sociedad
en este país es tan sencillo como hacerse
una cuenta en Facebook.
Las imágenes que estáis viendo son de otro
tutorial sobre cómo crear empresas en Estonia.
Literalmente, bastan 3 minutos para hacerlo.
Y diréis ¡Vale! ¡Todo esto suena genial!
¡Impuestos simples! ¡Tipos relativamente
bajos! ¿Dónde está la trampa? ¿Qué han
sacrificado los estonios para tener unos impuestos
tan competitivos? Pues ahora mismo lo vamos
a ver.
LA ESTRATEGIA DE LA BUROCRACIA 0
La respuesta es NO: Estonia no ha tenido que
sacrificar su estado del bienestar, tienen
salud pública, educación pública, carreteras
y transporte público. Es más, el transporte
público es gratuito para los ciudadanos.
Por supuesto, lo pagan en forma de impuestos.
Pero tu puedes ir por las calles de cualquier
ciudad Estonia y montarte en el tranvía sin
pagar un solo euro. Su sistema educativo está
entre los mejores del mundo. Y todo esto con
una deuda pública del 8,4% del PIB. Y diréis:
vale ¿Dónde está la trampa? ¿De dónde
sacan el dinero en Estonia?
La respuesta es eficiencia. Es decir, conseguir
el mismo resultado con menos recursos ¿Recordáis
que os decía que, en el año 2009, Estonia
despidió al 40% de su plantilla? Pues ese
fue el principio de toda una revolución.
Una de esas revoluciones silenciosas, de las
que rara vez se habla en los medios, pero
que deberíamos tener muy en cuenta. En el
año 2013 se aprobó la Nueva Ley de Servicio
Público (((New Civil Service Act))). Esta
ley decía cosas tan revolucionarias como
que, a partir de ese momento, la política
de contratación estaría descentralizada.
Es decir, que no es el Gobierno, en Tallin,
quien decide a quien se contrata o a quién
se despide. Es la oficina de Hacienda, en
un pueblecito perdido por los bosques Estonios,
la que decide si pueden prescindir de un trabajador
o si necesitan contratar a otro. Sin embargo,
aunque las contrataciones sean tan descentralizadas,
hay un objetivo impuesto desde el Estado.
Un objetivo a largo plazo: lograr que los
funcionarios no superen el 12% de la población
activa. Y para eso tienen un principio: burocracia
0.
¿Y cómo se reduce la burocracia? Pues de
muchas formas. En el año 2015, el Gobierno
hizo dos encuestas: una a los empresarios
del país y otra a los propios funcionarios.
En esa encuesta pedían sugerencias sobre
cómo aligerar los trámites burocráticos.
Es decir, que los propios funcionarios estuvieron
ayudando a reducir el peso de la administración.
Gracias a esta encuesta, Estonia se dio cuenta
de que las distintas agencias del Gobierno
usaban 14 softwares distintos de contabilidad.
Obviamente, esto generaba un montón de duplicidades.
Así es como se pusieron de acuerdo y eligieron
un único software. Algo parecido se ha hecho
con el uso de la información. Toda la información
fiscal de los ciudadanos está centralizada
en un único sistema, que se llama X-ROAD.
X-ROAD conecta a todas las agencias del gobierno,
a los bancos y a toda clase de entidades financieras.
De esta forma, la detección de fraude fiscal
es mucho más efectiva. Los bancos comparten
la información fiscal de sus clientes con
el Gobierno. Y lo hacen en tiempo real. Gracias
a eso, el 95% de las declaraciones de la renta
se hacen online, con sistemas tan sencillos
como los que hemos visto antes. Y, en lugar
de necesitar a miles de personas procesando
facturas o investigando fraudes, el mismo
trabajo se hace con mucha menos plantilla
¡Pero esperad un momento porque esto no es
todo! Ya sé lo que pensaréis muchos, sobretodo
si trabajáis como funcionarios: todo esto
está muy bien pero ¿Realmente esperas que
todos los funcionarios se dediquen a aprender
nuevos programas de software y nuevos métodos
cada año? Aquí es donde entra el programa
de formación continua. Gracias a las encuestas
que os he dicho antes, Estonia se dio cuenta
de que basta con formar a los cargos intermedios
para cambiar toda la administración. Los
cargos intermedios son el nexo entre los directores
y los trabajadores de base. Gracias a todos
estos programas, Estonia no ha dejado de reducir
los recursos que emplea para dar los mismos
servicios públicos. Para que os hagáis una
idea, sólo entre 2015 y 2017, Estonia redujo
su plantilla pública en 2300 trabajadores.
Tal vez no parezcan números grandes pero
hablamos de un país de 1 millón de habitantes.
Para que os hagáis una idea, toda la administración
estonia consta de 116.000 funcionarios.
¡Y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando muchos!
¡Ya me puedo imaginar lo que me pondrán
muchos en los comentarios! ¡Pues menuda solución!
Despedir a funcionarios. A nadie le gusta
que le despidan. Y ahí es donde entran las
ventajas de tener una economía tan dinámica:
el paro en Estonia no llega ni al 6%. Es decir,
que es realmente sencillo encontrar un trabajo.
De hecho, es bastante normal que una persona
deje una empresa privada para entrar en una
pública y viceversa.
Por supuesto que este sistema no es perfecto.
Y Estonia tiene muchos desafíos por delante,
principalmente, integrar a su minoría rusa
o la brecha salarial, que sigue siendo una
de las más altas de Europa. Ahora bien, objetivamente
es un modelo de país que deberíamos tener
en cuenta. Han demostrado que, con buenas
políticas, es compatible tener un estado
del bienestar, impuestos bajos y crecimiento
económico. De hecho, en cuanto a igualdad
de ingresos se refiere, Estonia es más igualitario
que muchos países con impuestos más altos
como España, Italia o Reino Unido.
Así que ahora la pregunta es para vosotros
¿Creéis que se podrían importar algunas
cosas del modelo Estonio en vuestro país?
¿Se os ocurre algún aspecto concreto en
el que se podría mejorar la administración
en vuestro país? Podéis dejarme vuestra
respuesta en los comentarios.
Y como siempre no olvidéis que aquí, en
VisualPolitik, sacamos vídeos nuevos todas
las semanas. Así que suscribíos a este canal
y dadle a la campanita para no perderos ninguna
de nuestras actualizaciones. Si os ha gustado
este vídeo, dadle a LIKE y nos vemos en el
próximo. Un abrazo y hasta pronto.